je suis désolé de devoir vous dire que
le président vous je n'ai pas un très
bon correspondant
il n'a pas répondu et j'ai finalement
reçu une réponse tout à fait je serais
tenté de dire l'âge mais en substance
exemple il s'appelle fait cadeau au
gouvernement philippin d'infrastructures
admirable et que ça devait lui et devait
se contenter de cela que le nettoyage
des anciennes bases nous les concernés
dans le caca mais l'action continue
c'était en avril dernier à l'occasion du
40e anniversaire de l'association
mondiale des amis de l'enfance
[Musique]
sa présidente caroline de hanovre
princesse de monaco est interrogé par
les participants sur les suites qu'elle
entend donner à une certaine lettre
adressée à georgetown où bush
[Musique]
monsieur le président il a été porté à
mon attention par notre antenne
philippines que des milliers de familles
et particulièrement d'enfants ont été
contaminés par des déchets toxiques près
des anciennes bases militaires
américaines aux philippines il faudra
attendre quelques mois pour que le
président réponde en la personne d'un
conseiller militaire de la maison
blanche
votre altesse merci pour votre lettre
adressée au président bush concernant
vos accusations de pollution causée par
l'armée américaine dans les anciennes
bases des philippines
[Musique]
nous sommes en 1992 suite à un vote du
sénat philippin l'armée américaine puis
bagarre
la base navale de subic et la base
aérienne de clark située au nord des
philippines se vide peu à peu de leurs
derniers de giresse
base que les états unis occupaient
depuis plus de 50 ans et qui jouèrent un
rôle déterminant durant la guerre du
vietnam
sites stratégiques pour la puissance de
feu de l'us army subic et clark sert de
garage pour la réparation et l'entretien
des navires et des avions
la présence américaine aura été
bénéfique pour l'économie locale
deux mille emplois créés rien qu'a subi
qu est ce n'est pas sans une certaine
tristesse que la population assiste au
départ des gi's
tristesse qui pour beaucoup va se
transformer en détresse
[Musique]
tony la journaliste local fut la
première enquête et autour des anciennes
bases
j'ai entendu parler d'histoires de
femmes qui ont perdu des enfants
j'ai vu des personnes malades avec des
irritations sur la peau des ampoules
on m'a montré des sources d'eau potable
sony par des treize d'huile maintenant
je travaille avec ces gens chaque fois
que j'entends parler de leur histoire je
partage à chaque fois leur douleur c'est
quelque chose de spécifique
vous avez des victimes dans des sites
contaminés avec des catastrophes
naturelles comme les éruptions vous
pouvez vous enfuir ou chercher un lieu
plus sûr quand vous êtes atteints par
des déchets toxiques c'est bien
différent des déchets vous tue à petit
feu
c'est mon unique enfant ma fille
s'appelle michael roth elle est atteinte
d'une paralysie cérébrale
elle ne peut pas rester debout
[Musique]
ma fille de leur s est opérée trois fois
du coeur elle a une maladie congénitale
d'une absorption d'eau polluée petit
fils michael est né avec cette
déformation au visage on ne peut rien y
faire c'est parce que sa mère l'a conçu
à une époque où elle buvait de l'eau
contaminée
[Musique]
la racine du mal la voici du mercure du
plomb des substances chimiques
abandonnées par le us army polluants les
rivières et l'environnement
la nature est devenue poison pour les
riverains des bases ce big ben est
devenu toxique ben est difficile
d'obtenir des statistiques mais on
estime que plusieurs milliers de
personnes sont contaminées
cette pollution un rapport officiel du
gouvernement américain l'avait pourtant
envisagée au moment de la fermeture des
bases
nous sommes en train de leur donner
l'occasion de se servir dans nos stocks
ils peuvent prendre tout ce dont ils
peuvent se servir c'est ce qui crée une
situation particulière nous essayons
seulement de rendre la plus sûre
possible une situation que j'estime
particulière en tout cas jamais non ue
vers cela aux états unis
toutes ces choses sont récupérés et jeté
dans les décharges
ce qui pose un problème d'autant plus
grave que ça se passe dans les zones
inondables en cas d'inondation est ce
que les déchets vont contaminer sunnite
mais comment expliquer alors que ce
rapport transmis au département de la
défense soient restées lettre morte
peut-être faut-il chercher l'explication
dans cette simple phrase de conclusion
le coût d'un nettoyage de
l'environnement pourrait atteindre des
sommes astronomiques
[Musique]
mea culpa de l'ancien commandant des
forces américaines dans la région
nous avions un grand centre de révision
pour les avions et de nombreux chantiers
de réparation navale nous étions obligés
de purger 10 danger vous toyer décaper
et repeindre les avions et les bateaux
avec tous les résidus que ça générait en
fait nous étions en permanence en train
de produire des déchets d'origine
industrielle hautement toxiques sans
aucune considération pour les problèmes
de pollution
il faut reconnaître que nous avons
laissé derrière nous des traces de
substances toxiques qui vont durer des
décennies
monsieur le président je souhaite
solliciter votre intervention pour que
soient prises les mesures indispensables
pour enfin faire face à cette situation
critique
[Musique]
on
votre altesse les états unis utiliser
ces bases selon un accord datant de 1947
et rien dans cet accord ne nous
obligeait à procéder au nettoyage de
l'environnement
[Musique]
plus de dix années se sont écoulées à
l'exception des bâtiments du
commandement il ne reste quasiment plus
de traces de l'ancienne base navale à
côté dans la petite ville de l'ong à pau
où plus de la moitié de la population
est composée d'enfants
la vie semble normal enfin tresses
jaster aimerait bien s'amuser aussi dans
les ruelles
mais son copain lui fait comprendre
qu'il doit s'économiser jester fait
partie des victimes
de l'eau contaminée je travaillais dans
l'ancienne base
j'habitais ici le long de la rivière qui
débordé nous avions l'habitude de boire
de l'eau on entendait dire qu'elles
n'étaient pas bonnes pour nous mais
j'étais déjà enceinte lorsque nous avons
eu la preuve que c'était toxique
bb c'est pourquoi mon bébé est né en
2000 avec une leucémie
et d'après le docteur ces duos d'échec
si tu suis des chimiothérapies
il vient de commencer a mis un
traitement qui coûte cher on a bien
essayé de vivre ailleurs dans un lieu
plus sûr mais c'est plus cher
on ne gagne pas beaucoup d'argent nous
n'avons pas un salaire suffisant et on
ne t'a pas à la fois payer un loyer plus
élevé et la chimiothérapie pour monfils
j'espère vraiment qu'ils vont nous aider
qui vont venir nettoyer autour des bases
pour que plus jamais les enfants ne
souffrent comme mon fils j'espère qu'ils
vont faire quelque chose parce qu'ils
souffrent d affaires
des traces de ce côté là il y avait les
containers il avait l'habitude de jeter
leurs résidus dans ces grandes poubelles
de l'autre côté il y avait plein de
résidus qui venait de la réparation et
de l'entretien des bateaux une partie de
ces containers étaient destinés à
recevoir les déchets d'amiante
je me souviens que les déchets se
transformer en une poudre qui se
dissiper dans l'air et nous on était
exposé à faire poussière bien plus tard
en 1985 j'ai appris que ces déchets
d'amiante provoquer des cancers et moi
je suis une des victimes
on m'a diagnostiqué un cancer il ya donc
des choses qui nous ont été cachés par
une partie du gouvernement américain ait
à payer maintenant et je suis à présent
train de subir l'injustice que ces gens
m'ont infligé
[Musique]
depuis le départ des gi's on essaye tant
bien que mal de tourner la page subic se
prépare à devenir un lieu de tourisme
mais aussi une vaste zone économique où
les états unis resteront présents à
travers des sociétés influentes mais on
y croise aussi des habitants qui se
demandent si on leur cache pas encore
quelque chose
aujourd'hui les frontières sont des
lieux de loisirs où l'on vient pour se
baigner ou pour pique malgré le
fait qu'aucun remède mais aucune
activité traitement de l'eau n'était
engagée c'est une sorte de situation
irréversible
un cercle vicieux pour moi il ya
toujours des restes toxiques ici et les
futures générations pourraient souffrir
sans qu'elle le sache car il n'y a pas
de signe de panneaux d'avertissement et
surtout pas de traitement de l'eau il ya
des choses vraiment suspecte la
pollution est toujours d'actualité
jay z est la fille d'un joker qui
travaillait a subi qu elle est une des
bénévoles de l'association des victimes
entre deux visites à des enfants malades
elle reçoit aujourd'hui les anciens
employés de la base
victimes de leur exposition aux déchets
toxiques beaucoup sont découragés
estiment que le combat est perdu
d'avancé pour jake pas question de céder
au fatalisme séance de motivation
nous sommes là pour parler de nos
expériences dans la base mais surtout
pour demander deux choses demandé
l'enlèvement des déchets toxiques et
aussi qu'il y ait un jour une juste
compensation pour tous les travailleurs
de la base et pour les victimes
je suis en colère car j'ai travaillé
dans cette base sans être informés des
dangers toxiques
ce principe élémentaire de respect de
l'homme n'a pas été respecté nous ce
qu'on veut
en tant que victimes des déchets
toxiques c'est que la communauté
philippine sache aujourd'hui qu'il ya
des travailleurs qui sont des morts
vivants
il se lit j'ai un grand rôle d'éducation
auprès des anciens employés
il faut aider ces gens à lutter pour
leurs droits leur ouvrir les yeux sur
leur situation
il s'agit de leur faire comprendre que
les déchets n'affecte pas seulement les
yeux mais la nature autour et que le
plomb le mercure sont en effet beaucoup
plus large qu'il ne le croit c'est
caroline de monaco
la princesse de hanovre elle a écrit au
président bush pour l'alerter sur la
contamination par les déchets toxiques a
subi quatre clark et qu'ils paient pour
leurs responsabilités
nous aimerions l'invité pour qu'elle
vienne sur le terrain et qu'elle
constate comme ici l'étendue des dégâts
et la situation actuelle des victimes
dans les zones contaminées
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui l'a votre prince
il souffre d'une paralysie cérébrale
on vient de lui faire passer un examen
du cerveau à l'hôpital ils nous ont dit
qu'il fallait démarrer un nouveau
traitement mais nous n'avons pas
vraiment les moyens et été quant à ma
fille elle a un problème moteur depuis
l'âge de 4 mois
on voudrait bien la faire soigner aussi
mais cela coûte beaucoup trop cher pour
l'instant on ne peut pas lui payer de
nouvel examen médical
[Musique]
au nord-est de subic bay direction
l'ancienne base aérienne de clark
c'est ici qu'en 1992 près de 5000
familles des montagnes voisines furent
relogés après l'éruption volcanique du
pinatubo
[Musique]
pina turbo n'élit pas de courant à vis
de sa suite à l'éruption du volcan en
1981 nous avons été relogés ici nous
avons vécu une vie difficile
entassés parquet avec une eau qui
sentait mauvais une eau qui nous
donnaient des maux de ventre des
vomissements des diarrhées des
démangeaisons
le gros problème ici c'était l'eau avec
le recul je me dis que c'était encore
pire que ce qu'on avait voulu éviter
avec le volcan car la lave au moins on
la voit on peut l'éviter sur la route
alors que cette eau on ne pouvait s'en
passer
on n'avait pas le choix on ne savait pas
que cette eau nous tuer à petit feu t on
c'est là que je vivais dans ces anciens
baraquements dont il ne reste que des
ruines
voilà à l'époque autour il y avait des
stations de nettoyage des avions avec
des produits industriels déverser tout
autour c'était comme ça mon sentiment
c'est que je ne pense pas que les
américains savaient que l'eau était déjà
contaminé mais des mots chien je me
souviens que même la végétation ne
résistait pas à cette eau il suffit
d'ailleurs de regarder ici tout a été
détruit
mais c'est ici qu'on prenait l'eau pour
se baigner pour boire faire la vaisselle
ça sentait mauvais il y avait des
résidus noir en surface et de l'huile
même je sentais que ça nous rendait
malade mais je ne savais pas que c'était
aussi dangereux et surtout que mon fils
allait tous mourir
[Musique]
à une quinzaine de kilomètres dean
habitent aujourd'hui angeles city où
elle tient une épicerie maman de crise
elles premier enfant victime recensée
elle a fait de sa maison un refuge un
lieu d'entre aide pour des familles
désemparées
[Musique]
avant de mourir mon fils dessinée
beaucoup et en particulier il aimait
dessiner des hommes des animaux
surtout il éprouvait le besoin de
dessiner comme il disait
une nature sans poison là c'est un
collage que mon fils avait fait avec
l'invitation de greenpeace dans ce
qu'ils sont venus fin 99 début 2000 avec
le rainbow warrior lorsque le rainbow
warrior est arrivé mon fils était très
excitée ils l'ont fait monter à bord lui
ont fait piloter leurs bateaux ils
étaient heureux mais montrer des signes
de faiblesse
il avait du mal à respirer il
transpirait on lui demandait si ça
allait il nous faisait comprendre qu'il
ne fallait pas s'inquiéter qu'il irait
dans un endroit où il serait mort
c'est comme ça que j'interprétais ce
qu'il disait
[Musique]
hélas là sur ces photos ce sont les
derniers moments que l'on a passé
ensemble
après il a fallu l'emmener à l'hôpital
et ça a été le début de la fin et sur
son coeur nous demandons au gouvernement
américain de rendre justice aux enfants
victimes au siège de la société de
reconversion de la base
on ne songe qu'à l'avenir bureaux
flambant neuf équipes de marketing à
pied d'oeuvre
et ce projet de technopole avec centre
commercial piscine futuriste aéroport
d'affaires infrastructures high tech
nous nous risquons pourtant imposé la
délicate question des déchets toxiques
sur la base nous n'avons pas vraiment de
preuve scientifique pour conclure à des
maladies causées par des déchets
toxiques sur la base de clark cross
encore faudrait-il le démontrer par des
faits d'ailleurs sur notre site il ya
beaucoup de sociétés qui se sont
installées et leur nombre augmente on en
compte déjà plus de 300
[Musique]
à la faculté des sciences de manille ce
chercheur ne partage pas cet avis des
preuves
tommy déry tong a accumulé un grand
nombre depuis dix ans nous avons un taux
élevé de maladies autour des anciennes
bases
nous avons un taux élevé de cancer dans
les populations vivant autour de ces
bars avec deux instituts spécialisés ou
heston et good run nous avons fait des
rapports pas toujours facile à
comprendre mais qui montre bien que la
pollution et la voici un échantillon
d'eau prélevé sur la base de clark où il
ya des populations qui vivent encore
actuellement
ces échantillons sont contrôlés
régulièrement en raison de la présence
de polluants
on a trouvé encore des traces de plomb
des pesticides
tout ceci nous indique bien qu'il ya
contamination
[Musique]
retour à la maison des victimes où la
pureté de l'eau est devenue une
obsession quotidienne
guy duel épidémiologiste à l'inserm
le problème des métaux lourds c'est un
problème aigu dans la mesure où il est
stocké dans l'organisme et il n'en sort
pas et peuvent provoquer chez dans les
populations un certain nombre selon le
degré d'exposition un certain nombre de
problèmes de santé
généralement ces problèmes de santé
touche dans un premier temps les enfants
les familles nous enceinte et leur
foetus
une petite fille qui a été exposé à
manille vingt ans après va exposer son
propre foetus même si à cette époque
donnée plus exposés aux métaux dont on
retrouve principalement des effets sur
le système nerveux central sur le
développement psychomoteur de l'enfant
principal
malheureusement il y a absolument pas
que de traitement connu pour l'instant
à propos des métaux lourds en tout cas
la seule façon de remédier au problème
c'est de éliminer la source de pollution
ou changée les populations de lieu
d'habitation pour éviter justement 7,7
ce problème de d'imprégnation manille
ambassade des états unis face à un
gouvernement américain qui fait le dos
rond
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
venir exprimer leur colère des
manifestations où l'on croise des
familles de victimes
mais où se joignent aussi des
représentants de l'église catholique des
écologistes est ce qu'on appelle ici les
fils am enfant né d'un père jihai
reparti aux états unis et dont les
maires n'hésite pas à faire un parallèle
entre ce qu'elle appelle deux types
d'irresponsabilité monsieur le président
des centaines de milliers d'enfants
mourront dans les dix prochaines années
des conséquences de leur exposition
[Musique]
votre altesse même si je devine que ces
réponses ne correspondent pas aux
souhaits je vous remercie à nouveau
d'avoir écrit au président
[Musique]
c'est d'ici de ce petit pavillon de la
banlieue de manille et que sont
organisées les manifestations
nous sommes au siège de l'association
people task force pour baisser ce qui na
qui comme son nom l'indiqué réclament au
gouvernement américain de venir faire le
ménage autour des anciennes bases
la revendication peut paraître angélique
mais ici on y croit dur comme fer
la revue de presse c'est l'occasion de
regonfler le moral des troupes
mais c'est sa voix si une coupure de
presse qui fait partie de notre
collection
c'est un article qui nous vient d'italie
pour nous c'est très important car nous
avons besoin de mener une campagne
vraiment global nous avons besoin de
mettre une pression internationale
nous voulons obtenir la sympathie d'un
maximum de population de manière à
pousser le gouvernement américain à
nettoyer ses déchets qu'ils ont
abandonnée pendant la période lille
c'était sur ses bases
c'est vers il en fait c'est un très long
combat
nous savons que nous n'arriverons pas à
une véritable solution mais grâce à
notre plan d'action on pourra peut-être
obtenir des mesures d'urgence en matière
de santé nous espérons aussi qu'on va
sensibiliser les gouvernements à
l'étranger et qui vont faire pression
sur le gouvernement américain
[Musique]
la cause des enfants c'est sa vie depuis
qu'il a envoyé deux sénateurs en prison
pour pédophilie
m eric malonga est très populaire aux
philippines de conférence de presse en
visite d'école comme ici il profite de
sa notoriété pour alerter l'opinion
publique
un combat qu'il entend bien porter au
delà des philippines poche nous avons
l'intention de pousser la commission des
droits de l'homme des nations unies a
mené une investigation de manière à ce
qu'il puisse établir une commission d
enquête sur les droits des enfants de
sorte qu'on puisse porter plainte devant
une juridiction pour les enfants
victimes de la contamination provoqué
par la présence militaire américaine sur
le sol fini il doit faire face à leurs
responsabilités
il vise l'irak et saddam hussein on lui
reproche de posséder des armes de
destruction massive mais ici aux
philippines en toute légalité dans les
anciennes bases militaires il ya des
armes de destruction massive de
destruction massive j'ai bien dit il ya
des gens qui on meurt ici aux
philippines et nous sommes pas des
ennemis de l'amérique
il faut absolument continuer à une prime
je pense que peut-être par le congrès
américain par les élus je pense que
peut-être certains citoyens américains
aimeraient voir l'argent de leurs impôts
dépenser à des fins peut-être plus juste
et plus plus utile pour l'enfance pour
l'humanité c'est une question qu'il
faudrait peut-être leur poser par le
biais de leurs élus je pense que
l'opinion américaine n'a pas été du tout
sensibilisés à ce problème mais il n'ya
pas que les états unis qui ont laissé
derrière eux des déchets toxiques je
pense que beaucoup d'autres pays peuvent
être incriminé est une prise de
conscience globale est tout à fait
nécessaire impératif on cherche tout le
temps à nous rassurer sur l'innocuité de
de certains produits ou de certaines
certaines offensives
seul le l'absence le risque minime pour
les populations et on a l'impression
qu'on a affaire à des apprentis sorciers
qui ne savent pas exactement où ils vont
et ceux qui manipulent le message de la
princesse caroline at il des chances
d'être entendu les apprentis sorciers
seront ils plus forts
ces derniers sont en tout cas prévenus
des citoyens amani comme ailleurs sont
bien décidés à se battre pour les sert
une autre planète à leurs enfants
[Musique]
m